uh yeah they're right on top
oh
all right
good
come on you're the one to ask
right
you're the one in charge well the the
only keys that need to go to there is
the vehicle keys but yeah the keys are
yours you have to keep your mind all
right
thank you
yes
other words I was making a difference
back there
yeah so you're going in the back of my
car I'm gonna search real quick okay
you got anything on him
got anything on him no no
no
okay first time 10 years
you know and you guys finally put your
feet down
okay one more question can I get in
contact with my brother about my dogs
who are your dogs I have three dogs
during the time they're at a townhouse
but
I just need my brother to be able to
take care of me okay we'll take care of
that we're not we're not you're not
going to church on the other side okay
you wanna turn them on now yeah
you can go back down anyway
[Music]
let's hook your hands up
awesome thank you brother
thank you
hey no way to put these in the front
right no that's not a thing fence policy
man yeah yep swing type
sure that way that's your stuff okay
so this doesn't follow us on airplane
mode just
kind of hadn't transported up there okay
just turn it over
hang on to it we'll grab it okay all
right sounds good
okay take your stuff
all right
excuse me what's up all right nobody
told me like what's happening oh I'm
just trying to take you and uh they're
gonna talk to you down there
they'll inform you everything down there
I don't really know they just called me
into transport area down where exactly
to our headquarters
okay
I've got your keys in your wallet keys
wallet phone oh they stuck
as my phone coming with me I think so
I just got what they gave me man they'll
bring everything else down there okay
okay
what happens when you get like a guy
that's like six five man
that's even more uncomfortable
[Music]
some people have Impalas
some people have impulse
even smaller
I have a question what do I do about
Madison
go figure it out
like I said I don't know anything about
what's going on they just told me to
come transport you so yeah
[Music]
thank you
in one thousand feet turn right
foreign
[Music]